the 18th of february 2021
is one of the most historic dates of the
new decade
this is the day when just another nasa's
mars rover successfully landed
on the surface of the red planet what
data has it received by the moment this
video is posted
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
the first and the most important
information beamed back to the earth by
the perseverance mars rover
is a detailed film of the landing
process
it is this recording that is going to be
useful for preparing for missions
in the future the beginning of the film
shows the spacecraft after it has
entered the planet's atmosphere and is
on its way to landing
descending at a speed of 5580 meters per
second
after that the rover drops its
protective heat shield
that was used for slowing down the
spacecraft
in about 80 seconds the sky crane
maneuver is performed
the descent stage detaches itself and
lowers the rover on a set of cables
to ensure maximal safety on landing
cameras located in the lower part of the
rover have captured the thruster jets
blowing away dust and small rocks at the
touchdown site
the video finishes with the controller's
words tango delta
confirming successful touchdown
almost immediately after landing
perseverance sent several images
captured with its hazard avoidance
camera
other higher quality images taken on the
same day
soon followed
this clear picture taken by a camera
aboard the descent stage
shows the cables that the rover was
lowered on to the planet's surface
this shot captured by the rover's lower
cameras is the first color picture
received from perseverance
the next chart shows one of the rover's
six wheels and the planet's surface
in addition to all those nasa published
one more photo on the day of landing
it was taken from the orbit of mars by a
camera on board the mars
reconnaissance orbiter satellite or the
ro
we can just make out the descent stage
of perseverance and the parachute above
the days that followed proved to be
exceptionally productive for the mars
rover
as it activated its on-board equipment
the pictures beamed back to earth
considerably gained in quality
in order to demonstrate the kind of
resolution the rover's cameras are able
to capture
and to allow us to appreciate their
capabilities
nasa published this picture
the next important thing that had to be
done by the rover was to test the sound
recording equipment
on february the 20th the rover was able
to make the first
audio recording on the planet's surface
where gusts of martian wind can be
clearly heard
a bit later nasa published one more
recording on its website
but this time without any interfering
noises from the rover itself
perseverance is currently checking its
basic technical equipment
a short while ago mission controllers at
nasa got the first status report from
ingenuity mars
the rotorcraft attached to the rover's
belly
according to the acquired data the
charge of the helicopter's batteries is
as high as expected
and its base station is fully operative
after perseverance drops it onto the
planet's surface
ingenuity will have a month ahead of it
before setting out on a series of test
flights
if ingenuity survives its first night on
mars
it will be able to successfully move on
to flying
excitingly as the photos and videos
taken by perseverance are in the public
domain
people all over the world were able to
witness the process of the mars rover's
landing
and a group of enthusiasts was able to
decipher the encoded message on the
rover's parachute
it spelled out dare mighty things and
also specified the gps coordinates for
the mission's headquarters
at the jet propulsion laboratory it took
just
six hours for internet fans to figure it
out
the clearly seen red and white pattern
on the open parachute is a binary code
spelling out the message
at this point the perseverance rover is
at the beginning of its mission
but even after just a few days on mars
it has managed to collect a lot of
really valuable data for us
of course the mission has just started
so clearly the most exciting discoveries
are still up ahead
and if all the other days the rover
spends on mars are as fruitful as the
first ones have been so far
our channel will definitely bring you up
to speed
in the meantime let's hope that
perseverance will deal with all of its
tasks successfully
and not encounter any major problems
while collecting rock samples and
generally data
about the red planet dear friends
feel free to leave your comments below
and hit the like button if you enjoyed
the video and would like to see another
episode about perseverance
let us know and we will make another one
at some point
in not so distant future let's keep in
[Music]
touch
you